[Music]
good morning everybody
and good afternoon if you're joining us
from
europe warm welcome to the american
enterprise institute
uh my name is albert rohak or rohaj
if you if you will if you if you're
still using the central european accents
uh and i'm a resident scholar here at
the i i work on all things europe
including the eu post communist
transitions democratic backsliding
in in both communist central eastern
europe
as well as transatlantic relations and
i'm delighted to kick off
this really exciting panel discussion
on a subject that is extremely
concerning to policy makers on both
sides of the atlantic
namely the kremlin's influence
operations
and hybrid warfare more broadly
for years russia has been providing
support
to political extremism in europe has
tried to
leverage uh economic and energy tools
uh to destabilize europe has looked for
fishers to
to to divide and and and and
throw off balance and and and confuse
and unlike the soviet union uh russia
today doesn't really have an ideological
agenda to export it really seeks to
divide throw the west of balance keep it
distracted
and that way the regime can both pursue
its ends in its immediate neighborhood
and also claim to the domestic
population that
the only alternative to domestic
stability even if it comes
at the cost of oppression is chaos
that the russian public sees outside of
russia um
the kremlin has seized the opportunities
offered by by the pandemic
it's been peddling its vaccine to
european governments government
at the time when the eu and the european
countries struggled
with vaccine procurement
obviously kermit has not provided much
information about the effectiveness or
safety of the vaccine
nobody has been vaccinated in by by the
sputnik vaccine and some of the
countries that
purchased it such as slovakia
but the subject has dominated the
discussion for the for the good part of
of the past two months it left the fall
of one government in slovakia led to the
departure of the foreign minister
in the czech republic a very pro-western
atlanticist
uh foreign minister so from the
kremlin's perspective
it is a success if you
can only think otherwise if you really
believe that the purpose of the
kremlin's
vaccine diplomacy is to is to vaccinate
people um so we'll be we'll be touching
on
on on some of these subjects in the in
the coming uh
50 something minutes that we have and
i'm thrilled
uh to be joined by this illustrious
panel to
to to to touch on these
on this on these subjects and i'll
introduce the panel in alphabetical
order i'll start with diaco bianda who
is the executive director of european
values in prague
one of the leading security and foreign
policy think tanks in the czech republic
uh i just cannot be stressed how
influentially important this
organization
which really is a relatively small
operation has been in shaping the
um the track debate of uh foreign policy
strategy transatlantic relations
hybrid warfare i think the influence of
european values has gone way
uh beyond uh the borders of the czech
republic and yacou's leadership actually
has been very instrumental in
in that regard he's also the first
european think tank to open an office
in taipei later this year a very very
impressive
very impressive move not withstanding
the bullying of the
of the chinese regime edward lucas who
is joining us from somerset
uh is a writer who has specialized in
european transatlantic security and has
written extensively
about russia for years he's a veteran of
the
economist but he wrote really quite
relentlessly about
about brazil's regime about its true
nature about
about its plans his 2008 book
really is remarkable and the new cold
war is remarkable in
anticipating so much of what has since
come to pass
in great detail and and and sort of
great
level of granularity so so i'm thrilled
he he has set aside some time to to talk
to us today
and finally uh a good friend maria
negovaya
is joining us from virginia tech where
she is a postdoc
at the kellogg center for philosophy
politics and economics
she also has an affiliation at george
washington university
where she's a visiting scholar the
institute for european russian and
eurasian
studies she has worked on party politics
on
european politics more broadly political
behavior she's written extensively about
uh democratic backsliding in
post-communist countries
she's written on russian foreign policy
uh
published in in major academic outlet
including western european west european
politics party politics post-soviet
affairs
journal of democracy democratization her
work has been featured in
new york times washington post
and and many other outlets um and i'll
leave you in
the very capable hands of my illustrious
ai colleague ivan last ratner
who will moderate the conversation ivana
is a
uc berkeley trained legal scholar who is
currently a gene kirkpatrick fellow
at aei where she is developing a sort of
two-pronged
uh research agenda partly on
international organizations and the role
of international law in
holding authoritarian regimes to account
and partly
on on the western balkans and
particularly the role
played by russia and china in western
balkans i should say
that this is a public event which is
being live streamed on our website
on our youtube channel everything you
say is on the record
i hope uh that won't prevent you that
i hope that you won't pull any punches
as a result of that and
i should also tell our viewers that they
can start asking questions
either by emailing our colleague lance
coconuts
l-a-n-s-l-a-n-c-e
dot k-o-k-o-n-o-s aei.org
or on twitter using the hashtag aei
hybrid warfare and without any further
ado
i'll now hand it over to ivana
thank you and i look forward to the to
the conversation
thank you dallyboy for your introduction
and um good morning everyone from dc
and i would also like to thank our
panelists today for being with us
and discuss this important question on
hybrid warfare strategies that russia
has used across europe
and the impact of buddhist influence
operations
so the main issue that i would like to
discuss today and try
for all of us to better understand is uh
considering the biden's administration's
pledges to strengthen
transatlantic relations how can europe
and u.s work together
to counter russia's malign activities
so in march uh u.s intelligence agencies
issued a report saying that russia
carried out operations to try to
interfere in the 2020 u.s elections
and maria you wrote a report
on russia's influence operations in the
u.s
and i would like to ask if you could
please share with us
your insights on russia's hybrid warfare
objectives in the u.s and if you can
compare that
to europe um and
if the means and methods differ does
that actually indicate that russia has
different objectives in europe
than in the u.s thank you
thank you very much ivana dalawar and
american enterprise institute for having
me it's a very important and timely talk
obviously
so to answer your question ivana uh at
least based on
my understanding of the existing um
findings on russia's operation in the
united states in europe
uh the goals of more or less related
in both regions and that is primarily
yes as
you have mentioned to undermine the
transatlantic alliance
as well as more broadly weaken the
existing liberal international
order uh so to speak and in an effort to
do that
russia implements very similar tactics
so to speak with an effort
to sow domestic discord disrupt
and discredited democratic governance as
well as undermine the us and the eu
international standing
and influence what differs in both
regions
is actually these strategic
opportunities existing on the ground
so for in europe for example you have
many countries with significant shares
of
russian-speaking population uh that
legacy of perhaps
you know communism and some kind of
links to russia
that provides many opportunities to
exploit this pro-russian sentiment
try to essentially uh so discord using
the russian population and is it's
easier for russia to reach out to its
groups
through its channels like for example
russian tv as i'm sure other speakers
will comment on that
uh is actually quite a powerful tool and
it's very competitive
in many eastern european uh regions so
it's easier
some ways for kremlin to so discord
because there's such large groups that
are very
amenable very susceptible or receptive
to the message that
to the messages that the kremlin sends
particularly given overall
dissatisfaction in that evolved as a
result of the transition
um in this region as well as
euroscepticism
uh in one of my recent publications of
party power politics
and uh virgin foundation i actually
showed that one particular
quality that um pro-russian socialistic
parties
have in common is that the electorates
share euroscepticism
whether on the left or on the right of
the political spectrum euroscepticism is
one particular
um characteristic that electorates also
these parties uh have in common uh the
other quality specific to past communist
region
is a higher cultural conservatism which
again uh just trying to play out this
sentiment overall um combining the
findings we see that
the at least my perception is that uh
the kremlin's approach is very
opportunistic
if there is an opportunity it's gonna
try and exploit
uh that opportunity and the other
quality of course is the flexibility of
the criminal approach
it employs a variety of actors directly
when directly linked
to the kremlin um you pretty much are
guaranteed that if a certain
um oligarch is in one or another way
connected to the kremlin at some point
you know like uh he or she usually he
will become uh some kind of a promoter
of the criminal interest
um there's also a variety of actors that
are not directly linked to the criminal
quasi-private
um and that allows of course a lot of
flexibility in implementing the goals
uh going back to the report thank you
very much for mentioning that uh the one
who published with my
author from japan cohere watanabe uh one
uh the influence and interference in the
united states domestically
we call it a moving target and
essentially the essence of our finding
is that
despite very successful actual county
effort implemented by the u.s
intelligence community and the policy
community
we still see consistent interference of
the kremlin in the us domestic political
process
and it evolves hence the name the one we
target
uh because there was a lot of successes
and then identifying and blocking these
actors
the kremlin's gotten has gotten quite
much better
in hiding uh from this identification
effort so many of the criminal link
actors
boards and trolls they actually adopt
much more um
lively personalities they try to
resemble real humans
better and they also learn to speak
better english uh
it's actually an important
identification strategy
uh so from that perspective actually now
even copy
large chunks of uh english text by
native speakers
in order to pretend uh that they're real
american for example citizens
um we also find that they try to hide
the origin of the message more
because being associated to the quran to
russia has become increasingly toxic
especially in the us
uh domestic political process that is by
the way quite
different from europe uh based on what i
understand and therefore they try to
hide uh the original message through a
series of
narratives launching operations uh so to
speak
uh also in some way i would say it's an
achievement of the
current operation because it was uh the
facebook and twitter have identified a
very successful effort in
have have implemented very successful
effort
in promoting and blocking uh russian
pro-russian uh russia
link linked actors in recent years we
see that the kremlin apertures actually
move to smaller platforms which are less
good in identifying those
um uh those actors as well as for
example using
um closed chat rooms private facebook
groups where there is less regulation
and there is
less monitoring as well so in this sense
it's a kind of
uh observing cat mouse game between uh
programming actors
and uh the us intelligence effort and
the us actors effort to block and
identify those groups
finally where we actually differ from
the report by the u.s intelligence
is that in our analysis we actually
identify now
we use the number of quantitative and
qualitative techniques
we actually see that as in the past uh
the kremlin tries to engage
the groups on both sides of the
political spectrum so the u.s
intelligence
actually concluded that was primarily on
the right we see these uh
activities to be directed towards groups
on both
far left and both sides of the political
spectrum many of you may have heard
about this
uh platforms uh peace data in uh
which unfortunately they're not quite um
um so it's not a very appropriate uh
wording in russian uh especially the
platforms were specially kind of
uh mockingly named after some i've seen
uh
words in russian but those were the
platforms that were designed to engage
the groups their naive uh unsuspicious
americans
on both sides of the political spectrum
in order to write and promote
programming uh narratives so that is
another similarity actually uh
with what we see in europe very
opportunistic
very um kind of indiscriminately
non-ideological regardless of of right
or left uh leanings
uh nature of the kremlin's approach
trying to engage
uh domestic groups in order to disrupt
the liberal order
thank you thank you very much
maria for this excellent explanation
um how russia has used malign activities
both in the united states and in europe
and when i think um about europe and
russia's hybrid activities i always
think about
ukraine and 2014
um and i'm wondering how has russian
hybrid warfare
evolves since then in terms of methods
objectives and tools and
uh what hybrid warfare tools has the
kremlin employed
during the ongoing russia ukraine
tensions
and i'm wondering if you can provide
example as to
how the russian methods and tools have
changed basically over the past seven
years
even if their objectives to create
instability as you mentioned
um has not uh changed so um any of you
may be
maria or edvard
sure is that for me hello
yeah look um
i i mean some difficulty here because i
agree very much with what everybody has
said already and many of the points i
wanted to make have been made by
dalibor and and and maria already
i suppose the the key thing i i think we
need to bear in mind
is that the
dissipation is getting more
sophisticated and as it's getting more
sophisticated it's getting harder to
spot what is
exogenous and what is endogenous and
so if you see and whether it's anti-vaxx
or anti-lockdown
or anti-any kind of anti-systemic
material now you even with
quite detailed analysis it's hard to
know is this a
um local person inside
our system who's got a justified
grievance
is it someone who's got a sort of
unjustified conspiracy theorists of
grievance
or is it um being amplified from
outside and that's really and that's
really hard now
it used to be very easy to spot russian
chinese propaganda because it was so bad
and there's a sort of darwinian process
that it's it's it's got it's got
better and that makes as
um maria was saying we have a sort of
cat and mouse game
i think the other thing that is really
important to bear in mind is that all
this really works
because of mistakes that we are making
this is a bit different from the sort of
completely
invented propaganda that we've seen in
other information operations that it's
basically relying
on real problems that we have
you know there's real skepticism
particularly among people of color
particularly in the united states about
the medical establishment
that's the basis for vaccine hesitancy
um
there is the european union
really did botch badly its response the
pandemic
we saw barriers going up all over europe
the whole idea of the sort of schengen
zone was uh given a real kicking and
particularly in the baltic states for
example which suddenly found they were
cut off from the rest of europe because
poland had just put up a
land border russian propagandists made
hay with that but they were able to make
okay with it because
it had actually happened that was a
thing um the
slow vaccine rollouts these are real
things
and i think that in the past we've
tended to
look at information operations through
the
sort of basic framework of analysis that
they're um
inventing um things you the lisa case
there was a girl called lisa but she
really wasn't kidnapped
and everything that it was in that that
whole episode was was made up and
there's been many other
examples of that and we also was hacking
and leaking where something was taken
from the private sphere put in the
public sphere
and the sort of arbitrage around that
with these information attacks it's that
not really based on hacking and leaking
they're not really based on invention
they're based on
real things that people real people
really do feel and real events that
really happened
and so to my mind the best kind of to
them
is not to think so much about the
information
dimension although it's worth doing what
we can on that
the best counter we have is to make real
people and real events
um
be different and make people have
greater confidence in the system
don't close borders don't um
muck around
public procurement in a way that makes
people sleazy or incompetent
and that cuts the ground from underneath
the um these are both russian and
chinese information operations
i think far more successfully than doing
information any tactics
anything else that maria you would like
to add and maybe
um make an emphasis on ukraine
uh yes uh thank you very much ivana very
much follow everything that edward has
said
i just i forgot to mention that in our
report uh with uh
we actually find evidence of the
criminal successful uh fostering of
polarization in the united states
uh since we actually run an analysis
quantitatively and show that
respondents in the united states on
twitter who more actively engage with
content that resembles what russia
propaganda looks like
we didn't have the tools unfortunately
to directly attribute uh those messages
to russian propaganda but
it was look like looked like something
russia would usually promote
so we see evidence of polarization in
that sense that engagement with such
content
correlates correlates with less uh
willingness to support the
president from the opposite count around
the survey right about
right before the um actually the year's
presidential election
so that is some evidence of a successful
uh effort to do
authorization on ukraine uh i have been
uh following
a little bit less unfortunately the
dynamic in ukraine in the recent years
uh but overall um our atlantic council
team um
um has done a lot of great reports on
this topic
uh and um with healthy jobs which are uh
headed by jacob
kolensky among others um those are the
dfr lab
that works on that what they have
identified essentially continued of
course
russia's disinformation effort in
ukraine this time more are focusing
specifically on
um domestic process in ukraine
it's a little bit harder now of course
after so many years of war
when the ukrainian population is much
less kind of
pro-disposed and susceptible to them to
the propaganda that the premium
um sense plus uh technically
some of the groups was more for russian
sentiments like the crimean war on
barcelona actually
like less under ukrainian control these
days so in some ways it's actually a
little bit easier
uh for the ukrainian government
nonetheless the penetration
and disinformation effort in ukraine
today is massive
it's uh very much focused on domestic
process
uh to uh so it is core domestically to
challenge and undermine the politicians
that are not favorable uh to the kremlin
as well as more broadly um create
satisfaction and uncertainty around the
way democratic institutions function in
ukraine
uh for example in the last election
significant chunk of the disinformation
effort
focused specifically on um on the
election um
in ukraine there is also of um so
all sort of different um
kind of targeted attacks designed to
make them um say the actors that the
kremlin views more hostile uh such
for example ukrainian uh
church kind of to undermine the
influence
uh in ukraine uh so from that
perspective yes unfortunately
it continues and one of the results of
this continued operation
uh was the recent actually blocking of
some of the russian channels by uh
president zielenski
it's a little bit of a debated um uh
debated contested issue
in ukraine i'm sure other colleagues
will be able to comment on that
but one particular problem in ukraine i
wanted to draw attention to
uh because of course of all this
russia's effort uh in the
recent years starting with 2014 um
ukraine there was a lot of
ukrainian sentiment um in ukraine but in
somewhat left out uh russian-speaking
population
outside of the government kind of um say
i'd say
interest zone uh that in some ways
unfortunately especially in recent years
given that ukraine
has not been particularly successful on
its reformist track
uh it actually creates a lot of groups
that uh unfortunately
become susceptible to the disinformation
operation by the kremlin again
so therefore one of the possible policy
solutions and i'm hoping we will be able
to get there
is trying to reincorporate these groups
by creating channels of information for
them
that are effective that are competitive
for the kremlin channels and at the same
time integrate them
into them into more pro western uh uh
messaging
i don't think we should be repeating the
mistakes that we have done in the past
right which already allowed uh provided
the ground with the winning two
with the winning hand uh back in 2014.
so that's one of the particular pro
problems to which i think we should all
pay attention
thank you very much maria so jakub i
think you also wanted to
comment on ukraine and later and i would
like to ask you actually about
czech republic so um please share with
us what you think about ukraine and then
i have some questions for you about the
czech republic
i think on ukraine is quite something
similar what we have seen across other
european countries so what i just wanted
to point out is that
uh i mean ukraine is a testing ground
unfortunately for russian aggression
in military and non-military terms as
well so i mean
if we are looking into i mean
disinformation
done by elite captured individuals
this is exactly what i mean we see china
doing pretty pretty
well and pretty successfully across
europe but the russia has been doing it
obviously for i mean many years
we have seen it through the kgb active
measures manuals in the past as well
during the soviet union era but this is
ongoing
uh but just what i just want to say is
that russia
today is quite successful so far to
actually co-opt
individuals who actually do the russian
or kremlin's messaging on
the kremlin's behalf so those are not
only
outsiders or external players doing it
in ukraine against ukraine or
in czech republic against czech republic
but quite often those are local
individuals who are actually co-opted
for various reasons
who are working as de facto agents of
influence of
the russian federation and when i see it
as a major problem
is that this is actually happening not
only in ukraine or generally in eastern
central eastern europe
uh like in the region we or i come from
uh but
but very clearly this is happening in
western europe as well and
i mean we as generally speaking the
expert or national security community
have been
i would say relatively good in
responding
uh to some levels of the general
disinformation tactics russia does at
the
international stage i mean to some
extent there is some knowledge and
understanding of this even though we are
not fighting but
back enough but at the level of elite
capture and how this
is used for strategic disinformation by
russia
we are very very much not successful
and i mean obviously no stream two and
russian economic projects in germany
or france or countries like czech
republic are quite successful
and the the reason for it is that there
is uh
still a level of i would say
understanding of normalcy or let's say
the normative line or norm
is still quite low which means that it's
acceptable
to actually be a proxy of the kremlin
quite often
do a program in messaging if you don't
do it
um in a silly way if you are quite smart
how to do it
uh and so you could actually achieve a
lot on behalf of russian foreign policy
interest or
the kremlin oligarchic money depends on
who is paying you
but this is still a major problem for
many of us
uh because and we could see it very
clearly now in the czech republic with
uh
where which you mentioned ivana but with
the gru
incident which actually basically what
happened was that we actually had a
russian military organizing a
terrorist act or act of sabotage which
actually meant
um meant at the end that in 2014
uh two ammunition depots to buildings
with ammunition actually exploded
on the czech territory killing two czech
citizens
uh hundreds of czech citizens had to be
evacuated
and there were billions of czech crowns
used for repairing the damage so quite a
major damage for
czech republic um and what we now know
is that the gru russian military
intelligence
which de facto means russian army has
actually
organized and done this so what i'm
trying to say is that
after this was revealed some two weeks
ago from now
uh the there has been a massive
russian disinformation operation engaged
against czech republic
i mean not only from russia itself but
also within the czech republic
where we have had quite a lot of russian
proxies and assets
who are now being mobilized on behalf of
the kremlin's messaging
like the czech president milo zeman who
is a russian puppet
or a couple of our parts of our
parliament on the far left like the
communist party
or the far-right parties uh so um i'm
trying to say that this is actually a
long-term problem
so when there is an incident where
russia is engaged in like this gru
attack in 2014 in verbage
czech village uh what actually happened
is that
those individuals those proxies and
assets are
mobilized and and quite clearly here in
the czech republic we could see they are
quite successful
in um mixing up the messaging so czech
republic is not
understood as a trustworthy ally by its
allies because
because if you look through the czech
political spectrum who is in the
government who is in the
presidential office those people are not
really trusted by our allies
for good reasons i don't trust them
myself uh
so at the end why would anybody really
go out and help czech republic despite
what happened
and we we internally keep saying look
2018 salisbury attack the what the
what the russian intelligence did in the
uk
resulted in expulsion of 153
russian intelligence officials with
diplomatic cover from across
euro-atlantic countries more mainly
and the closure of russian consulate in
seattle
what this was this is the benchmark of
uh response
we might argue that this check case is
much more significant because it's an
attack on a
nato military facility nato state
military facility to be exact
um tuche citizen died directly because
of this
so i would to some extent i would argue
it's a level of salisbury or maybe a bit
beyond that
uh but still we are waiting for the
response and i'm afraid the response is
quite limited
first because of how russia is
successful in czech republic is
successful
in not organizing and mobilizing its
allies
and second because the allies don't
decide to to do it that much
because they don't trust czech republic
and and not
trust and maybe do not want to go ahead
with that and just to finish up
obviously we will see more because
clearly now there is more evidence
coming up
or in bulgaria where where
it looks like the similar kind of gre
operation actually happened in some
of the ammunition depots over there and
some people some
bulgarian citizen died because of this
as well so clearly this was a regional
activity not only in the czech republic
so i think we'll see more in upcoming
days and weeks but sorry if i was long
no thank you very much for this this is
exactly something also that i wanted to
ask you and just to follow up on this
can you also just briefly tell us a
little bit about this new
um hybrid warfare strategy that was just
issued
in czech republic because it's a
fascinating document
um so you can just briefly um comment on
that because
right after that i would like to ask you
a follow-up question on the eu
so yes uh so what happened
is that uh i mean in the czech republic
there is there are basically two groups
of people
first those international security
institutions most of them are on the
good side so
our national security institutions more
or less are quite good i would say
the problem is that much of the
political leadership in the current
government
is to some extent co-opted or corrupted
so which means that there is this
disparity which you see in many
countries across europe as well
uh so right now we have a strategy which
is called
national strategy for uh countering
hybrid
interference uh essentially what it is
it's it's really about
uh russian and chinese influence in the
czech republic and what should china
public do against that
obviously it's just a policy document so
it's just a basically a piece of paper
which was approved by the government
which is good
but what it does is that it it actually
forces all the government agencies to
work together
uh because that that unfortunately so
far has not been really the case
uh even in a country of 10 million which
is which doesn't mean that we are very
bad
very big uh but it means that quite
often
there is uh i would say old school
understanding of like external security
is this
is uh is uh organized by petrol defense
more or less
and internal security by ministry of
interior but obviously those things
overlap a lot there is a big
big and we video hybrid trust coming
mainly from russia we could see very
clearly
how internal and external security
actually is more or less one security
altogether
so what morris does the government
document but what is happening now is
that the government
is actually drafting an action plan much
of it will
likely be classified uh because it will
be quite
quite specific over what will what will
be done internally in the czech republic
for basically making it more resilient
on on
quite many levels because after the gre
attack was was revealed publicly
finally even the current government
which is uh quite a weak
because it's dependent on the
president's will with uh russian puppet
so it's hard politically but now there's
a public push
to do to actually at least promise a lot
we will see how much everything will
actually happen yeah good luck with that
um and on that note
i know that you testified before the
parliament on a very same topic
and both of us were there so um and i
learned over there
so many great uh policy recommendations
um
given there was several months ago i'm
just curious if you can share with our
audience
what you should do about this issue
and where is over there and given that
even some eu countries are actually
if i may say pro-russian um on that note
um how can we have like a solidarity on
this issue
i think reaction to this sort of
specific gre incident uh
actually what can happen is that eu
countries can can and should expel
uh some of the russian intelligence
officers under the only cover on their
soil
something what we have seen after the
2018 russian attack in salisbury
that's exactly what should be happening
i hope there might be happening some of
it soon
only so far i believe slovakia
uh bulgaria and baltic countries have
responded so far
if maybe i forgot one or two but more or
less that that's the case till now
but to my knowledge more of it is coming
but it will not be huge
unfortunately so that's the that's the
that's the first part
but uh honestly this is not deterrence
this is important it is happening
but the turn appearance means that the
kremlin would look
look at europe and say look we have done
this and they have really punished us so
we will not do this again
uh so i'm thinking what what else should
it be there are many options
i mean only if the europeans if us as
europeans
would look at the way how the how the
u.s sanctions on russia stand
for for example those sanctions on
russian oligarchs
linked to the kremlin uh basically if
europeans actually take you as sanctions
and implement them in europe
i would say at least we have done done
part of it as well because for example
there are many individuals who are on
u.s sanctions list
but they are not on eu sanctions
the example is vladimir kunian former
kgb general who is essentially
a major proxy of russian influence and
intelligence
in germany france or or austria
or in the czech republic as well but
this individual is on the u.s
u.s sanction list but europeans are
very happy that this this individual is
actually organizing russian influence
operations
across centre and parts of western
europe as well so those people should
not be allowed to enter europe
for example at least and honestly again
this would be a defensive measure
we are we are entitled to defend our own
soil
and so this would be purely defensive
but we are not even doing this as we
should i think
thank you very much jacob so edward you
wanted to comment on this
um question as well yes i i think
there's two kinds of deterrents there's
deterrence by denial
and there's deterrence by punishment and
deterrence by denial is when you
make the attacker feel there's not
really any point you know if i try and
attack
fort knox with a peashooter yeah
my peas will bounce off the concrete and
i think that it's worth looking at the
countries in europe that
do deterrence by denial in the
information sphere
and chief among them i'd say is finland
and the finns
this isn't something you can implement
overnight but the finns
start off by teaching media literacy in
schools to seven-year-olds
they have very close cohesive links
between the
different parts of the information
system between
media and and government um law
enforcement intelligence
everybody understands that finland can
be attacked with information and they
pull together
and the result is i mean if russia still
tries to attack
finland with historical narratives
saying that the
finns are fascists
finland tried to attack the soviet union
but it kind of bounces off really and i
feel that the russians are to some
extent losing their enthusiasm
for attacking finland because it just
just doesn't work whereas other
countries
when they when they do it through
history or polarization or any of the
other things they've got
um it it does come it it works better
so i think in addition to what jacob's
been saying about
deterrence to punishment which is if you
do um any kind of hybrid threat against
us we will
catch your spies throughout your
diplomats
put um your people on our visa lists and
so on
um it's also just what really really
worth digging down and seeing how the
countries that succeeded this
do succeed and i think that there's been
a remarkable reluctance
um in old europe to learn from new
europe perhaps i would say western
europe to learn from
from east and that's since i put finland
as in the east and eastern half
and there's also been a bit of an
unwillingness i think in the united
states
to think about the information system as
a part of
democracy that can be attacked there's a
there's a kind of default
reflex to go straight to the first
amendment and say well that's the most
important thing and
the first moments fantastic i wish we
had it in in britain and in european
countries as well
but the first amendment is is not in
itself a defense of the information
system against people who are
um attacking you with um lies or hoaxes
or
or scare stories you need to think about
it a bit bit more broadly
um and there are countries that do this
so my key would be let's not try and
invent the wheel again and again and
again let's look at countries that are
getting it right and
and do it um i'd also one other point i
think is very important is there's a
danger of sort of reflective control
here
but one of the things the kremlin would
love would be if we would putinize our
own system
in order to defend it against putinism
and i think that
we have to be quite careful about um
adopting
um sort of extraordinary measures
against information attacks because they
actually
under take us off the moral high ground
and make it easier for the
um russians to say there's no real
difference between your system and our
system and you
rebound radio liberty and you ban
chinese telly so what's the difference
so i'm not saying we shouldn't do these
things we need to think very carefully
about
about um these sort of punitive
um measures and work out if they may be
creating more
if adopting punitive measures that
creates more problems than they solve
thank you very much edward for your
comment and on that note i would also
like to
link that to your report on the
coronavirus thing because
even russia amplified false theories on
the coronavirus such as that the covet
19 for example
originated in a us bioweapons lab
so i'm wondering if you can share with
us the kremlin's again you know
objective tools and methods for the
pandemic disinformation campaign
as a specific example and if you can
share with us how effective the russian
disinformation campaigns have been in
promoting false narratives
about the pandemic both in the u.s and
um in europe well it's a huge subject
and i'll try to just touch on a few um
things that
i think the first thing to say is that
this this wasn't a
step change for the russians they
carried on doing things that they'd been
doing before
and did them in a more intense and
sophisticated and
effective way but it wasn't like with
china where china went
went off in a new direction we'd never
seen china going down the far
far falsehood approach and warfare
diplomacy was also quite
you know is a new thing for for china so
the
one has to see what russia does in the
sort of um
continuum of what they've been doing
before um
you're absolutely right that they um
recycled many anti-western
narratives the west is failing um the um
there's a sinister plot that the western
vaccines are being tested on
innocent ukrainians who are going to pay
a terrible price for this
um laboratory monkeys
in the for the western uh pharma
industry
um the bio weapon you've mentioned that
of course echoes on operation denver
which was the
soviet attempt in the 1980s to blame the
cia for the
hiv aids epidemic
um that was particularly strong in based
in
georgia and picking up the presence of
the luger lab in georgia and saying this
was something very
sinister um there's also
i i'm quite interesting the the one of
the things i'm always have to remember
about russian disinformation is it's not
homogenous
and just as i think maria was saying
earlier they appeal to the far left and
to the far right and i'd say also to the
greedy
greedy middle so in germany it's you
know the left wing
the ifd and schroder who all hate each
other but actually they're united
by the fact that i think you like them
but
equally in this there was a strong
heterogeneity in the messaging so at the
one hand they were saying
sputnik is the best vaccine it's the one
that really works
take it you'll be safe that's great and
at the same time they're also saying
vaccines are dangerous
and um making out that you know there's
a you know
can't be too careful um so this sort of
uh i think we we
summarized it in our report by saying
that the russian line is
both at the um the viruses
simultaneously a plague
and a hoax and they
went off from that in all directions um
you know let's all panic
um he has a fake cure and watch it watch
out for those five gtars
and and i think the overall message is
not
the the the aim of this is not to have a
particular
um outcome they're not saying let's use
this in order to get
candidate x elected in election y
it's part of this general idea of
corroding trust
trust within countries and trust between
countries
because when trust goes down it becomes
much easier for a country like russia to
um to to get what it wants and so in the
end they don't care
what half so long as it's bad and that's
a bit different from the chinese
um messaging which is in some cases
is is just straightforward corrosive but
also
has a sort of more positive side of
wouldn't the world be a lot better if it
was wrong
run by china
thank you edward and i well
i received numerous questions for you
and
one of the questions that keep popping
up is actually
um china-russia cooperation in this
information
and i would like to ask both of you
advert and yakube and if you can comment
on
the russian disinformation corporation
in europe and can you tell us more about
this corporation and what happens
um what has beijing actually learned
from moscow and vice versa and do you
see
evidence of china's ccp applying those
lessons
around the globe yeah
so i think i think china's late to this
um in terms of
of getting i mean chinese efforts used
to be very sort of
ridiculous in the way that russian
efforts were ridiculous 10 years ago but
the
um they're they're catching up fast i'm
sure they have learned
from russia i think i think one thing
that was quite interesting was that
russia didn't try and blame china for
the virus
20 years ago when i was the moscow
bureau chief of the economist
the russian press was full of sort of
quite racist sort of yellow peril
watch out the chinese are coming and
every sort of scare story and
um nonsense about um the chinese were
both sort of
primitive and sophisticated and sinister
all at the same time
and that's all gone you you really have
to search very hard in the russian media
to find anything
that's kind of anti-chinese so that was
one thing that you know they could have
played that card and
and they didn't um we didn't come across
any signs
of real strategic coordination um
there's a bit of narrative amplifying
you know stuff that was tweeted by one
side and then it's been retweeted by the
other
um but we we didn't think that there's a
there was a sort of high level
information summit where they're sort of
disinformations
bars on both sides got together and said
right how are we going to play this it's
been
opportunistic um on both sides
i think that the i mean the key message
for the for the chinese
is we've got this we have really
um dealt with the outbreak
with our um
quite harsh measures but they work and
so democracies failing and
autocracy or chinese communist rule
is working and that was a message
because for a time it did you know if
you forget the fact that the virus
originated in china
um that was quite a um that that you
could argue the way the west's response
was
it was late and patchy and the chinese
response was being pretty
um vigorous i think was one of the
things i mentioned is that the chinese
are really going up
for this hegemonic discourse control
they want to
close down discussion all over the world
if it doesn't suit china so we saw in
germany for example they went after a
children's book
just very anodyne children's book which
was sort of aimed at
german eight-year-olds we just had the
sentence um the
virus the outbreak started in china and
they organized a social media campaign
and um letter writing campaign and they
had diplomatic protests
and they got this german publishing
house to apologize
and pulp the book and produce a new
edition which does not say that the
virus
came out in china now what's interesting
about that is a
the the level of detail and focus that
it requires to do something like that
and secondly you can't imagine the
russians doing it
if you imagine someone and finding
something comparable about russia
and putting it in a children's book and
saying
maybe you know russian carbon emissions
are melting the arctic tundra
or gonna die or something i mean however
offensive it was the russians the idea
that the russians would be
have the the organization and the focus
to target a particular
publisher of a children's book and get
them to withdraw you just
can't really imagine it can you imagine
russians in germany being
organized to write a you know hundreds
and hundreds of letters or the russian
consulates in hamburg complaining
there's just a different level of of
attention
so i think that shows how much more i
know that's why i'm more worried now
much more worried by russian
by chinese disinformation it's backed up
by real organizational muscle
and um in in a way the the russian
effort
isn't on the other hand more and about
russia when it comes to other things but
um but
i think yeah i fully agree with what
edward said i think
what russia and china share are some of
their strategic
objectives in europe not all of them but
some uh
and clearly they they align um they
they they they see the world in a
similar fashion
they both wonder revenge against the
united states
they both want to in a way push out
american u.s presence from europe in any
way
and they both want europe to be let's
say
more divided or separated from u.s
uh policymaking in national security
issues that's clearly what
they both want but they have different
options how to do it but clearly we have
seen in the disinformation messaging
this is clearly what we've been seeing
as well
i mean china clearly tried to blame uh
everybody i mean blame the u.s mainly
for the pandemic
trying to try to try to show itself as a
savory or savory of europe
somebody who is saving europe from the
pandemic when china tried to
deliver medical goods medical equipment
to some places across europe and then i
think the
overall political or geopolitical map
actually
has became more transparent during the
pandemic
because we have seen countries or states
which decided to be
or which are long-term chinese allies
proxies or puppets
who essentially played again the chinese
card in this card
sorry in this game and clearly there's
hungary that serbia
there are there are some efforts in
other countries like italy or even in
the czech republic
where part of the czech political
spectrum essentially kneels to china
for no reason for to some extent for
money but basically this is what we have
seen as well
so i mean to some extent russia and
china share some of their strategic
objectives
clearly we see china learning from
russian mistakes or russian successes
because clearly if you look through
chinese international broadcasting
they copy a lot from what rt has been
doing what uh formerly russia today a
russian tv station
which is a channel or communication
channel of the russian
state um do not mistake it with
journalism but
clearly this is exactly what china
learns from and
i would say the difference is that
russia is seen as a
urgent military threat across many
places in europe not everywhere but
quite often it is while china is not
seen as a military problem for europe
uh which to some extent is
understandable if you think about
only hard security in a sense of kinetic
action direct action
but if you think about cyber security
logistical
security or many other areas now we
finally have a nato document nato 2030
which is basically saying look we need
to prepare for
the china challenge china problem china
threat
as nato not only as the us or only as
our militaries but as nato as a
political security uh sorry political
military alliance
uh which is good because now we have uh
uh
now we have this uh this move which is
important because basically there is a
big divide across europe
where you see basically germany and
partly france
pushing for a very soft policy on china
in every regard
uh we have some elite captured
individuals and governments across
central and eastern europe
who are basically on the chinese side be
it mainly the hungarian government here
some parts of the czech governments
previously some other people across
europe
but now we have uh countries across
i mean lithuanians estonians romanians
partly poland as well even though paul
is much softer
on china than others in this region but
so far we have seen that
there is a awakening on china and there
are
there are wedge lines there are dividing
lines across europe right now
and you could see that there will be a
lot of question marks or
i would say political discussions and
disagreements
among european countries on china uh
it will be and that's something where we
uh because on i would say on
under russia the discussion more or less
the discussion is set across europe you
see who is who
who is uh countries have their positions
set and they don't change much
regardless of what the russian actions
are while on china
that's dynamic that's changing what the
position of countries are across europe
yeah thank you yakuben you actually
mentioned a very important topic which
is the role of nato
um and in 2015 nato adopted a strategy
so
i'm wondering if maria you could share
with us
um the role of nato in countering
hybrid warfare operations um
because probably that would be one of
the avenues when you can see
the transatlantic corporation on this
issue
or if any other person like here would
like to comment on this so
i will comment a little bit on the
broader account
efforts which includes uh net operations
as well as the other
um uh kind of institutions that partake
in this
uh endeavor uh so what we see works and
what we see
uh doesn't work as well uh first of all
uh the very issued questions here i just
wanted
to add a little bit of optimism to our
discussion that uh the very fact that uh
as
edward has pointed out for example um
and i have mentioned as well uh the
russian
actors actually now actively looking out
for local
actors on the ground in the specific
countries that are more
favorable to programming narratives and
uh essentially amplify those narratives
i think in some intelligent standards
demonstrates the
effectiveness and success of the culture
effort it's very toxic
uh to be openly embracing the russian
agenda
and openly affiliating to program to
kremlin
uh russia more broadly in today
contemporary u.s or european landscape
but that's
exactly partly the result of what uh
jacob has pointed out
uh because of the uh really the
understanding of russia and its
influences there's some consensus
with regards to the kremlin and its
malicious influence so that is success
uh another uh kind of successful policy
which we see also
in our report is actually uh
identification
labeling actors is being associated to
the kremlin and russia actually works
quite well
uh it does reduce significantly
engagement with um
uh discontent promoted by the sector so
this policy should be uh continued
censorship upon also work but they're
more are short-term
uh well uh unfortunately like it's
actually just a short-term solution
these actors tend to emerge after some
time
i do agree with jakub that we need a
much more uh consistent
and well-developed policy of sanctions
and essentially punishing
uh deterring the aggressor uh there is
no there's no continuity there's not a
lot of
alignment between the u.s and the eu in
that regard
he remains much more pro-russian and too
careful
of taking uh harder steps and honestly
at this point one stats questioning them
you know ourselves what is it that the
criminals should do for the you to
finally awaken and to take
more serious action about against what's
going on real the kremlin is organizing
terrorist attacks
all across europe and there is no
significant counter action
so to go back to your uh earlier
question ivana some successful
achievements and nato counties
information activities as part of this
effort were
fairly successful but there is much more
to be done and but unfortunately it's
more of a political
decision that requires some stronger
commitment on the side of the politician
uh to sanction and prosecute some of the
aggressive actions on the on the part of
the kremlin sectors
i was muted um i wanted to say uh edward
would you be maybe willing to also
comment briefly on nato we have three
more minutes
um so that was also one of the questions
that i received
if i may uh on nato i mean
clearly we see there is um let's see
there is a divide which if i put it in
very simple terms
there are countries in europe who want
to see for example
if you're speaking mainly about china
here at first
the countries who want to take china
only as a political and economic problem
that's mainly the big countries in
western europe germany france
italy partly spain as well uh so their
preference is to
that europe actually takes the china
policy through the eu channels
which means that the voice of uk
us and canada is missing and then there
are countries which are which we see
see china mainly as a national security
and an economic problem
uh more or less those are countries some
countries in central eastern europe with
exception of hungary
uh some of the nordic or scandinavian
countries as well
uh and some of them are basically saying
we are very happy with the american
approach which is now supported by the
uk and canada to
canada less uk more within nato which is
let's let's really start discussing how
we how we take the china challenge which
will take several decades for us
how we take it mainly as a strategic
military
geopolitical problem through nato uh i
know this is this is not just a false
dichotomy i think this is clearly
closed our our the complex of our real
problems across
eu member states how how we generally
speaking see
the china problem and then on the russia
discussion
i'm afraid we don't see much of movement
so basically
regardless of what russia does what the
hostile aggressive actions russia does
we do we do have some level of military
response which is good
there is a deterrence component in the
baltics some of it in romania in the
future
but to some extent we can push back
against russia in ukraine
to a limited extent but if you speak
about non-military russian aggressive
activities
i'm afraid we don't see much of movement
for stopping it because
the current state of play is not what
europe
likes uh because russia is still hurting
us still hurting our national security
interests
still making damage to european
democracies and we
as europeans are not stopping it uh
because we don't
put put hard enough and it's not only
about defensive measures
like building our own resilience that's
important
but at the same time we effectively need
to put
harm to the aggressor so that the
aggressor actually stops the aggression
i know and i know this might seem very
theoretical but at the end
aggression does not stop because we are
more resilient aggression stops
when the aggressor thinks it doesn't
it's not worth it
and we are not at that point of
discussion among european policy circles
anymore
i mean we are not there yet to put it
that way we are no
anytime russia does anything really
aggressive look at
recent cases in a recent three four to
five years we only do symbolic
action we only do very symbolic
sanctions we we put two or three
local russian policemen to eu sanctions
it does not hurt the kremlin at all
so that's our problem that's what i
think our main point of policy
discussion should be in the future
thank you very much um it was a very
very um
important discussion discussion also
nato and i received so many questions on
this topic so
apparently our audience is concerned as
much as we are about this issue and one
thing that i have to say
is that russia's hybrid warfare
operations are here to stay and i
genuinely hope that
um this discussion on hybrid warfare
operations
that russia has used across europe and
the e-book to put its influence
operations help us understand a little
bit
more how can europe and u.s work
together to counter russia's malign
activities unfortunately due to time
limitations like i cannot ask
um all questions that i received so i
would also like to thank our audience
for
um being concerned about this subject um
and i would also like to
um thank all of you um and dalibor
for joining us today and discussing this
tremendously important topic so given
that u.s
midterm elections are almost in 18
months i really really hope
that the u.s can also learn a lot from
experience and you're where i'm also
coming from so i also personally care
about this subject i will thank you so
much for
this wonderful conversation thank you